the first sandwich in history was
thought to have been created by rabbi
hello who made this meal for Passover
we've got apple and horseradish which I
know sounds disgusting but it's somehow
works but this meal wasn't known as
sandwich until John matzo goo the fourth
Earl of Sandwich came along in the 18th
century our legendary tale begins in
eighteenth-century England where
Montague was on a 24-hour gambling
bender hey guys Montague do not like any
interruptions while gambling it's
possible that his impatience led to his
invention come on do the next hunt I'm
eating yes do give us a minute I want to
win my money back the story suggests
that eating and gambling at the same
time did not happen in Monte goos world
this could be because players hands were
busy dealing with a fork and a knife or
if they ate with their hands they would
get their cards dirty now ko roast beef
between two slices of toasted bread
would be the official first sandwich
hello I want you to try my sandwich no
it was amazing Montague cannot hold his
food in one hand while gambling with the
other now time to take every last
shilling from go from blundering bull
which led everybody to say hey I'll have
the same as sandwich and the story goes
that this is how the lunchtime favorite
God's name and why we continue to refer
to this meal as sandwich
[Music]